working for the weimar qdd District
Council is rewarding with competitive
salaries highly active social groups and
strong career advancement opportunities
we're focused on serving our community
and when you build a team of over 300
dedicated qualified and friendly people
you can be sure good things are going to
happen the staff have a great
relationship with counselors and
community board members and we're all
here for the same purpose and that is to
make one a hurry a great place to be in
partnership with our communities
why Mac ideally district is just 15
minutes north of Christchurch our
district combines the best of town and
country with the urban centers of Rangi
order kaya poi Oxford and Pegasus large
productive rural areas coastal
settlements and small rural townships
it is also one of the fastest-growing
districts in the country and that
variety and challenge makes the WDC an
exciting place to be a lot of the work
we do is unseen sewage water community
support building the Foundation's a
growing community thrives on we designed
the parks build the roads maintained the
pools and we plan for the future of our
district
[Music]
and we're good at it our award-winning
teams are respected in their fields and
have a wealth of experience to share
with those starting their careers
Council has been really supportive to me
and training experience and mentoring to
become a chartered professional engineer
frequent social events friendly
co-workers and advancement opportunities
all make our Council an excellent place
to set up a long term career
I've had all sorts of opportunities from
professional development right through
to new job opportunities that have been
able to grow and enhance my skills and
let me do new things around the
community however for a lot of us
perhaps the greatest satisfaction comes
from helping to build a district people
are proud to call home I love that I get
to come to work every day and work with
fun and energetic people who really like
to make a difference in our community
so if you want to work with us in making
Waimakariri a great place to live visit
our recruitment page Waimakariri govt T
dot NZ
foot / curriers
[Music]